quickly McKee and that's how you started
up
and it scouted out school systems for
trotty and rice
JaVale McGee tipping the Nugget
subscribe to baby the 2010
who's bought with the hitter head to
McGee
[Applause]
[Music]
punched it on Murray and people were so
excited that season to go and rightly so
about how Kuzma as a score he showed
some other things
Bernadette's who have high hopes for
this season they won Sunday against LA
and playing their second game is a nice
speedrun DOTA McGee
when ball was at UCLA I know it's a
different three-point line but he did
shoot 41% about theirs but B stops it
over the head of Damian Jones turns the
fatal Rondo OnPoint pass over Jones
big-time finish by McGee
[Applause]
know what this kid is not a joke he's an
NBA player he's one of the best in the
world simply sitting at home joking
about his rockets have hit five of their
first cities from the field McGee has
hardened Onam de Mayo the game throws it
down and easy spindle 24 games if they
still 165 Ali Optima game catches
gathers and throws it down on a perfect
pass from Rondo huh
Casey P Stephenson such a different
looks for the Lakers Makai looks great
well underneath wonderful lob to McGee
who finishes last play this fee mates
did a great job of setting it up waited
waited and here he goes off the rebound
who's my shovel pass LeBron doughnut the
key he'll throw it down 7 assists for
LBJ Porter shooters for Denver 44%
Lakers 41%
he is climbing the ladder check handling
those balls in LA
McGee
coaches at the intermission will stress
the fact that they feel fetters god
that's enmity the finish for believe
they needed by two on the plate for the
bronze pointing and saying go out make
sure I get it to you 42 to 40 acres and
he would be aware when you see him on
television to transition bucket by the
Lakers for those with at least 65 shot
attempts
[Music]
there it is delcampo fishes are going to
get together that plays a larger made
nice touch pass volley in the air with
its this end of the floor now has a
clampdown McCullum's goes around but
Becky is sadder to block it again LeBron
gets backed by media at the back court
just watch it and assert himself all fit
pass and applause that gives it up to
the key who throws it down more good
things happen when you move ball and
body
[Applause]
that's a story that I did not [ __ ] I've
never heard you say him to McGee's a
beautiful offensive basketball now held
up to 38 points in the paint that the
Lakers themselves didn't have a great
offensive game that's a good dish
what rods a slam dunk by mcgoun Lakers
down by one Bazemore attacks baseball
all the way to an epic he was there
Jamel again a streaky player already has
a thirty five point game this year does
Trey on Lakers have missed the playoffs
five straight years the last time they
went was 2013 when Dwight Howard was a
Laker they had missed the playoffs only
five times in their history prior to
this stretch has have been individually
and collectively they will have a
legitimate chance to not just get to the
playoffs but advantage nice pass Ingram
to JaVale the key and a quick four
nothing lead ball nice tip right to
James James was six of eight from
downtown on ice mass inside the key and
it easy to with JaVale McGee Lakers back
within six at the vision the ability to
put down in fact and then make the foot
Curtis will bring it out again van Dobbs
from Gobert all they come over at McGee
swats it and most importantly keeps it
inbounds through out of five that's 40%
season average here comes ronzo ball
great dish
been thrilled with his defensive effort
that's been something even though he's
wint wanting to score in your dish to
McGee they've been really pleased to it
always in play people most my gonna take
us through the glass to show you that
last move by JaVale offensive rebound
does a great job and keeping his pivot
foot looking job of running there off
and so far for the laser curling comes
up protect that ramp 14 of the team's
the only one that's kind of fallen off
is Phoenix underneath gee he's got
another one key contact with his body
before you expose the board they're not
getting content free look at that brick
by Evans never get a great outside
shooter kicking it bumbling stumbling
you see what JaVale did that's the
smartest thing possible that's bridges
playing above the rim now that big
regulators
McKey protects the rim leather look at
that play by javale
look at this week's to play without is
it even foul that's the most impressive
thing whether it's 68% tonight which is
right around their season average
biggest lead of the game the team that
takes care of it better than anybody in
the league rejection de pride javale
mcgee since Kody you bear to go to the
rim not fade away from it people
depending on how long he's out really
you have two weeks to do severe damage
to your playoff chances grant gets it
inside find a giddy let them right at
the rim you Thunder here's what I'm
talking about there's a lot of guys in
this league that don't go up to make
that play realizing they already have
one foul JaVale McGee Lakers shooting
just 32 percent from the field but only
down one but the slam
another nice setup for lumps of all
instead of going downhill draws two
defenders and he puts McGee in position
to effectively dive to the hoop and
finish at the cup that's outstanding
offense initiated you'll make the trip
to Salt Lake to play on Friday night
Ingram's good pass and McGee stops it
over to running after a great first half
by the Lakers Ingram Drive stripped down
low but it goes right into the hands of
McGee and I know you want the Rams to
win the Super Bowl we said yes
automatically and why not cuz these are
later for a Rams fan the beautiful
finish right there by McGee
wait Garden can't play tonight
encouraging Wiggins to keep continuing
to press the issue jumped by Mikey Otto
a host that guy he'll salado's here in
La Salle's right in my face
just a beautiful delivery there by Rondo
an equally impressive finish by JaVale
and I think this second group if they
can operate where they come in
transition did run right now but you
look how the defender for all up into
making everything difficult except for
that one throw it down and lay out by
fadia's of using his other arm to tap it
home that he is young for Memphis
Tennessee what the George attacted at
the other end JaVale finishes but a
Bullock who started 44 games with the
Pistons this year starting nothing new
for him with he on the pick-and-roll and
that's how you get off to a great start
how these combinations and rotations
will play out remember Irish shoot step
3 at 43% not I was good out here on
scoring and gets another rebound here
nice pass to McKee for the slam and
quickly Brett Brown calls timeout and on
this one pcs he sees there it is powder
up into your picture
man advantages they agree Bradley failed
as trying to the second of a back to
back to the first time this year
got two piggies a little more force that
he wanted us to avail after the nice
pass by who's the easy deuce
across the time line and all the sons
are gone is trying to Oh Saint play now
I don't know what they were doing on
that play 8 and again way out on the top
three to play Lakers down still buy a
bunch 15 it is unreal
but on the other side mark while all
this is going on James makes a nice pass
in the Gayle at the Throwdown needing
six now to tie Michael Jordan nice pass
here to Rondo from James and then the
key with another dump he's got six
points for LeBron because if one for a
roll the distinct block by Jove they'll
get that out of here like swatted out
about something hard when you're getting
the block shot slapping the ball doesn't
give you a choice right now without
Lopez good play by pcp to help control
it after the block by the game alone on
its way you bet shut down it go
making the block shot and keeping it
inbounds and letting a teammate that's
not the way they wanted to see
rejections quarter game the pace is
going to be important right now times he
gave it up to Drummond usually make the
right play in that regard
with a one-handed slam dunk that's the
eighth of suits for that dish LeBron at
36 13 that's a beautiful lob off the
dribble rod taps it gonna get it right
back caldwell-pope LeBron downhill he
goes spinning good dish by LeBron one
into the rivers JaVale he's right back
to the line he can bring the Lakers soon
within one and he could tie his career
high with that in his six attempts this
Kings team played last night they beat
the sun's the other day and he does
control it I don't think the trailer is
caldwell-pope hits the front of the rim
tap out by the heat and another topic
that's great movement by the Lakers foul
and three-point opportunity coming to
JaVale up with that big mittens
throw it down John Wall and Bradley Beal
dominating at that core I hope you've
the white Howard add it to the team
brings so many more
as you see - bill McGee finishes with
the dunk right there winning now being
to check the gloves for creative
marketing in another beautiful inside
steep ascents of hitting the key does an
excellent job of a superstar yeah once
you get the other superstar on that lob
to a Mike he's had five different guys
thrown the loss tonight meanwhile
Caruso's thrown some beautiful passes
that's his fourth assist the McGee
throws it down petition again Machado to
McGee's and Quin Snyder it's not
entirely pleased with the lights defense
I don't want another assists but it's
still Utah Stanley Johnson is in he's
playing some good basketball too lately
taken away another Pelican turnover
that's helping keeping the Lakers in the
Japan down the middle egos and one and
she's but it's all about the Lakers
turned them over HCP headed to pack
draws two defenders and here comes to
Vail nicely runs play Bosnia pelicans
McGee gets away as he found the role
from Caruso Hill on the other end all by
himself gets fouled and he's got another
we go we could spend the rest of the
game on that the shot is blocked by
McGann snow going down playing anywhere
Elysee you were playing three on three
every day after practice and during
practice
right where to put it that's number one
on the laws of category there's another
dump this time the alley-oop and the
finish by McGee fly by the scholar
Sefolosha just did walk that way then
all the opportunity the world go back
the keys right there to help reject its
possession in this game caldwell-pope
team up by three I got discovered this
throws it up then JaVale throws it down
very nicely done as it turns out 22 bore
tonight for McGee Joe Johnson you got
Josh Smith you know he's in it to fail
Mangin bells nasty this year you know
Hall of Fame coaches you know all all
around by the way you know Stu got
mistaken for George Gervin earlier this
year well you know did you [ __ ] this
what he does in his quiet way both
quarters tie games I look for him to
take over another assistant Caruso I'm
going to look at that 12th assists as
develop hammers one home look I get
money had been a thoughtful in the
players what what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content